hey guys I'm Daniel and welcome to D LM
model lifestyle in this video I'm gonna
give you 15 haircare minutes that people
still a wrongfully believe let's get to
it I have a dream that's all I need I'll
make it up there is so much can't
believe hey if you're new here to my
channel subscribe and click the
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos now let's start with
the first minute
hair products causes you to lose your
hair or to go bald myth absolutely false
the fact that is that your genes
nutrition and stress determines if your
hair was thought to pull up not good
hair products well unless you put
something really strange in your hair
some people believe that it can cut your
hair it makes you grow faster that's
false your hair grows from their roots
not from the ends of your hair so
trimming your hair will not make your
hair grow faster now if you want your
beard or your hair to grow faster I've
added a few products for your interview
description that will help you up
drying your hair naturally is better
than using a blow dryer boss the fact is
that too much heat can damage your hair
but if you set your hair dryer to the
lowest heat setting it will not damage
your hair research is actually shown
that exposing your hair to water for too
long while air dryer can actually be bad
for your hair because the interior of
your hair swells
if you wash your hair with a sitting
shampoo and a-seven conditioner your
hair gets used to them false your hair
won't get shot suddenly when you use a
difference shampoo and a different
conditioner if you want some good
options for some food and conditioner I
thought up a few for you innovative
description that you can check out
what causes dandruff dry scalp causes
dandruff balls dry scalp doesn't cause
dandruff it's actually the opposite
dandruff is actually caused by to oily
skin so if you don't wash your hair
enough or if you just use the hair
products and you don't wash them out if
you struggle with dandruff added some
good options for in the video
description that will help you out
combing your hair over a long period of
time is very good for your hair boss it
is actually the opposite the truth is
excessive brushing can do more harm than
good because you can damage your hair's
outer protective layer by causing
friction and breakage over time
now some people believe if you wash your
hair too much it will become very oily
well guys it is actually the opposite if
you don't wash it enough it will become
oily and don't wash it every day
but every two or three days should be
enough now you've probably heard this
before but if you pluck out one gray
hair two or three gray hair will grow in
its place right this is probably the
weirdest belief I've ever heard it's
just not true if you get one gray hair
it just means that more will follow it's
just time now sometimes when your hair
grows you get their split ends right
some people believe that you can recover
the split ends with good hair products
it's just not true it's probably because
of false advertising but it's better to
go and trim your hair
another myth that some people believe
wearing hats will make you go fall it's
just not true
another minute if you do not wash your
hair your hair will wash or clean itself
that's just so weird to believe it's
just not true if you don't want your
hair and your sculpt you will just get
dirtier and did you probably heard this
one before as well nits and the lice
they like dirty hair balls they like
clean hair another belief out there is
that you're stuck with the hair
thickness that you're born with it's
just not true guys the fact is your hair
texture can change with stress your
nutrition and your age as well boldness
where does it come from from mom from
debt well I believe because that's what
people told me as well when I was
younger it comes from your mom's side
but the truth is you can't blame mom or
her family for you going bald it comes
from both sides from mom and dad side
[Music]
smoking can actually make you go grayer
quicker they did some studies and they
found that people who smoke they're
twice as likely to go gray quicker than
those who do not smoke so that's another
reason for you I can throw away the
smokes
apart from cancer and for you guys it's
building school a lot of guys in school
still think oh yeah I'm so cool if I
smoke smoking does not make you cool
your personality makes you cool now
remember I added those good hair product
options for you in a video description
down below so it's a bit easier for you
to go and check them out and do your own
research that's it guys if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
click the notification belt so you won't
miss the next video
that's it Cheers
[Music]